i'm determined that's why i was
desperate when you send me that message
going serves me right for sticking my
head i was like no no this is not how
this is gonna go appreciate it this is
not how this is this is not how this
should ever go
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest is a friend
of the show in a restaurant james
cavallini welcome to trigonometry thank
you very much thank you for having me
both listen man it's great to have you
on i wish the circumstances were
different we'll talk about that in a
second but before we get into that tell
everybody who are you how are you where
you are what has been your journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us right so uh
both my parents came over from italy
uh to open restaurants in in the uk my
father was part of the sort of first
wave of italian restaurants that opened
up remember that we've only really had
restaurants in this country for like 55
60 years
my dad settled on a little place in
kentucky high street called portico
which opened in 1967
i believe
and then uh started working his absolute
butt off as hard as he could um and then
got married to my mum my mom joined the
business again
and you know fast forward 55 56 years
and here we are still going strong and
it's a you know it's a restaurant where
we go to celebrate birthdays and
occasions and all of that
you're great the food's great
everything's great
um
but there's been some events recently
yeah haven't there
yes so basically the whole point about
having a neighborhood restaurant is you
have to be a central part of your
neighborhood i believe and that you want
to plug yourself in as much as you can
into the community you want to be if you
want to be successful you've got to be
indispensable right so when
in the good times and the bad times for
example so during covid we made sure
that everybody was taken care of in
terms of dropping around food to elderly
people and vulnerable people and
obviously when things happen around the
world that your customers are interested
in you want to be part of that you
really want to plug yourself into that
because it's very important
and it's a very emotional business and
you want to you want to be there for
your customers when they when they need
those kind of those kind of events right
and um
jk rowling who is
a woman that i admire greatly not just
for her hard work but also for her
courage as well
um
basically with suzanne moore ex-guardian
columnist another woman who i admire we
decided to raise money for jk rowling's
charity in ukraine called lumos
uh lots of people got on board
uh we decided not to publicize the event
prior because of the negative attraction
that it might bring with it
and then after the event um
joanne jk was kind enough to basically
put out a tweet thanking me for raising
money for lumos we raised almost 20 000
pounds which is one night's dinner which
is you know not bad
and all that money is going to go to
help you know orphans in ukraine and
help kids whereas you know who genuinely
need that money
um unfortunately because she has her
views which are entirely you know
fair enough in in my opinion people then
jump on the bandwagon and i'll start
getting you know one star reviews on
google and you know don't go to this
restaurant because this guy's a
transphobe and this and the other and
then i'll go to work one day and find
that the place has been the windows at
the front which we had sort of tempered
security glass has been smashed
another pane of glass being smashed
somebody's got entry into the place
and uh ransacked stupid stuff you know
like smashed up a bit
bottles of booze that kind of stuff with
their left
now it's really now what's really
important is that
there is zero
hard evidence connecting
the physical attacks and the online
stuff
the online stuff you know
is coming from trans rights activists
because
you know because they say things like
that i'm a homophobe i'm a transphobe
and all this kind of stuff which is
absolutely baloney
but
the fact that it happened 24 hours after
the first the first online attacks
happened made me very very suspicious
how many times have your restaurant been
smashed up in in the in the 55 years
that has been in existence
i mean you're always going to get some
sort of break-ins but we haven't had any
trouble for at least a decade right and
then it happens 24 hours after that yeah
okay right and
what was that like turning up at your
restaurant
and just seeing the the effect that it's
had
the thing is that when
the first thing you feel is just just
like
you know you just like defcon five
levels of anger
you know you just think well why the
hell do i have to deal with this kind of
crap yeah that's the first thing and
then you realize well you know what why
shouldn't i have to deal with it
everyone else in the world has to deal
with it with crap why should i be any
different right so like you know the
whole why me why not me thing yeah you
know
um
and then you start to realize and then
i don't know man i mean it's like maybe
it isn't connected maybe it is a
coincidence the truth is i you know will
i ever know i don't know i got another
person you got other people now online
you know somebody now from florida has
got involved in telling that they're
going to talk to the place
you know so it's like i don't need this
kind of stuff man it's like apart from
the fact that
you know jk rowling's views are jk
rowling's views my views are your view
and my views and my views and everybody
has their own personal views it's like
it wasn't a gender critical event we
weren't going around saying to people
we support
you know
the we support you know the exclusion of
trans people from from women's only
space we weren't saying any of the sort
we were there exclusively to raise money
and uh and to help you know a different
situation in ukraine and that was it
i i just can't believe that we're having
this conversation really
when did you start noticing that
something was up was it the moment that
the tweet came out and you started to
then start to see responses or did it
take a little bit of a while uh it took
a little bit while because i'm very
careful about what i put out on social
media i mean most you know i think i
think you have to be guarded especially
when you've got a public facing
restaurant and also i don't like to get
involved in politics with my customers
and i you shouldn't be i honestly
believe that if you're
if you've got a public business
you should be there for the public and
and it doesn't matter if people are left
being right-wing trans rights activists
are gender critical as far as i'm
concerned everybody's welcome in the
restaurant because they're there to
they're there to have by the way that's
always been my experience like we get on
but i don't know what your political
views are because that's not what we
talk about yeah but why would you why
would you bring that up over dinner like
you don't want to go and ruin somebody's
decent dinner and go and talk about
religion or politics it's just like just
leave them alone yeah you know they're
there on a date night or they're there
for whatever and you know and they're
there to have a good time and you're
there to facilitate that process unless
you don't want the date to go well
and so that's that's actually it so the
idea that we kind of like you know put
out this take this political stance is
absolute baloney right but obviously you
can't help have a bias by liking certain
tweets and i've liked certain tweets by
julie bendel and suzanne moore of things
that i think are eminently sensible
personally and so people then
link two and two together and come up
with the wrong number and therefore
start calling me a transphobic homophobe
and all this kind of other stuff did you
ever think that you'd be in that
position where you put on an event yeah
which is not connected in any shape or
form to this to this particular issue
yeah and then you just get sucked into
this vortex where you become another
talking point in the culture war i think
that at the end of the day it's almost
like
it's like spin the bottle some days on
twitter you know who the outrage is
going to get directed at you know and
you guys have probably had a lot more
than i have i mean it's quite i mean
this is the yeah but james see sorry to
interrupt there's a difference man like
what we do is political by design yeah
right if when we get [ __ ] on social
media we're like well that's fair enough
it's what we do i mean the show the show
is called trigonometry like that's fine
because we discuss controversial issues
and some people aren't going to like
that yeah but you didn't do that this is
this is kind of why i really wanted to
to speak with you about this because i
just i am so angry about this on your
behalf because
look i don't think it's legitimate for
people to go and destroy your place
whether that's online by writing fake
reviews or physically yeah even if you
did a gender critical event but you
didn't even do that
it's just this person
who happens to have written some really
really popular books who happens to have
taken by the way a very nuanced and
carefully worded position on the gender
issue
and you did a fundraiser for something
completely unrelated with her and now
you're coming to your restaurant which
is a family restaurant you've got kids
there you've got people there right
you've got staff there and it's it's
getting attacked
because you you stood next to a person
who said some things that some people
don't like yeah that's basically where
we're at that's exactly where we're at
and you message me afterwards going like
it's sort of something along the lines
of serves me right for sticking my neck
out you didn't even stick your neck out
you didn't do anything
yeah
there is that you didn't do anything i
know i know but the thing is that at the
end of the day people will say well it's
guilt by association yeah people and
this is just to play devil's advocate
people say well you should know you
should have had an event with jk rowling
because you know she's not [ __ ]
hitler mate she's not here i mean
but do you know what i'm saying
of course yeah yeah i totally get it
colin i totally get it i know i know
it's bonkers and the thing is that i
don't really care about the break-in i
know because and that's partly because i
don't care about for two reasons one
because it's a pain of glass if it was
my house i would have cared where my
wife and my children sleep yeah that
would be different but i've also got a
big 55 kilo mastiff at home so she would
have dealt with that
so i don't really care about the pain in
the glass i don't really care about the
man's section because at the end of the
day it's only stuff yeah okay i do care
about the one style reviews because that
because as you know having a digital
business it stays on there forever
you know and somebody calling me a
transphobe and i can report that to
google and i can say to google look this
is bs you can see that this is bs please
can you take it down and then they see
that that gets taken down so they start
getting clever about it and then they're
like the owner is really mean and the
food's crap yeah it's like it's like
come on man it's like feminine from you
know i'm not always mr way of sunshine
yeah but like you know like leave the
poor chef alone he's been there 35 years
and he knows how to cook a bowl of
spaghetti yeah the fact that you've got
these reviews what kind of impact does
it have on your business it's huge
especially now coming out to tourist
season like you've had three years of
the most torrid
possible time for hospitality right
you've had lockdown then unlocked down
then masking then social distancing then
you can only serve outside and it's
pissing down with rain and you know what
i mean as you've got all that crap to
deal with
you're just coming out of that
we're now coming into a massive economic
recession food costs are through the
roof staff crosses through the roof your
customers feeling the pinch as well so
the absolute last thing you need now
is
you know a ship claw a [ __ ] cloud of
basically problems
so it's just bringing more stuff to the
fore which you just don't need
and at the end of the day um you know
like i said your digital it's like your
digital shop fund most people will check
out a restaurant on google before they
decide to walk through the door most
people will read an amazon review before
trying to buy a product now so whether
you like it or not
you have that digital shop fund and it's
literally the equivalent of somebody
like you know painting on your shop sign
do not bother eating here this place
will give you listeria or something you
know that's what the that's what the
equivalent is so you will lose and you
will never be able to measure how much
business you'll lose because of it
because you don't know how many people
will look on that and see those one-star
reviews and think
well you know they're not going to know
the new ones yeah a lot of them won't
even realize what's happened they'll
just see one lots of one stars and god
this restaurant has gone downhill yeah
yeah exactly and the way that the way
that we're set up as well
you know from an evolutionary
perspective as well the fact that you
know i want you need about 25 or 35 star
reviews to counter back to counteract
every bad once they're reviewed because
a negative comment holds so much more
sway than a positive comment you always
remember the things you did badly you
never remember the things you did well
that's just human nature that's with all
of us you know so a once overview is
like there's i'll just stick a five-star
review above it it's like it's not that
simple
it's not like for like
you know i think andre agassi said that
when he you know he said you know
the thrill you feel when you win a
tournament is nothing
compared to the dejection you feel when
you lose
you know and and that thrill goes like
that but the trajection stays with you
forever and it's the same with online
reviews you know that that one star
thing is really massively massively
damaging and people don't realize
because they just think that's just a
bit fun i'll just take one one star
apart from the idiot who said he was
going to burn down my restaurant who i'd
quite like to meet in person
[Laughter]
with the master
right there but but we're joking about
it but
as somebody who has received death
threats we both have
even there's the logical side of your
brain which is going look this person is
x y and z
but there's still a little bit of you
that goes well hang on a second yeah i
don't know this person yeah
i don't know what they're capable of i
agree yeah i agree i agree it's the it's
like the theory of the drunken driver
always has the right of way yeah
like if a guy's craving down the road on
the opposite side of the road going
straight for you you're not going to say
well i'm in the right so i'm just going
to stay where i am no
it's like just get the hell out of the
way yeah
hey francis have you decided what to get
your dad for father's day same thing as
always a couple of pints down the dog
and duck plus a new brexit means brexit
car sticker to replace the one i got him
last year mate brexit was in 2016 do you
not think he might want something a bit
more up to date like a new ridge wallet
this is mine it's smooth sleek stylish
and it can hold 12 cards and there's
also a clip on the back for cash as well
it's not going to create a bulge in your
trousers like those bulky old wallets
it'll make your dad look like a top
level player
great idea he can also put his brexit
sticker on it which means a problematic
older ladies are gonna love him
yeah okay the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
just one wallet for the rest of your
life rich are so confident in their
product they'll give you 45 days to test
drive their wallet that means you can
get the wallet use it and if you don't
like it you can return it in 45
days unlike brexit
because ridge are such great guys
they're going to give you 15 off and
free worldwide shipping and returns
that's 15
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special promo
code which is of course trigger
this is why i'm so angry james because
you know you you are a fighter and
you've always have been and your
restaurant has gone up and down and and
you've always
worked extremely hard and that's
actually what we usually talk about the
importance of working hard and being
courageous in the face of difficulty and
i really admire that about you eve and
in this situation too
but i'm angry about it on your behalf
because what this is is intimidation and
bullying yeah
and it's trying to stop people from even
going near a person who happens to have
an opinion that some people don't like
yeah yeah but they didn't even know my
opinion i know that's what i'm saying
i'm like one step removed from the
opinion i just happened to own a bricks
and mortar site
where somebody with an opinion raised
money for charity well actually i raised
my chat with her and with suzanne yeah
you know and it's like it's like the
whole guilt by association thing is just
absolute lunacy
it just doesn't make any sense
whatsoever and i think it's interesting
because you know you look at the
profiles for people
who do criticize you on twitter you know
and you look at the profiles of people
who are you know writing these one-stop
reviews and there is you know sort of
correlation of
you know the more deranged the comments
are the number of flags and the number
of little emojis after their name right
so you think okay fair enough maybe make
these people maybe that's just
maybe they're just having a tough time
with life whatever maybe they're angry
maybe they're incredibly resentful i
don't know what's going on with their
lives so who am i to judge
but leave me the hell alone man
it's like take out your angle on some on
something that's worth fighting for yeah
this is not worth fighting for me having
uh we you know helping to raise money
for orphan kids in ukraine is not the
right target here you know and i think a
lot of people i think they're just
confused they don't even know where they
are now they don't even know what the
target is because i think that things
change so quickly now on social media
that it just seems to be this kind of
endless
you know barrage of abuse like i said
it's almost like a game of spin the
bottle it's like well the bottle's
spinning over there so let's all just
direct our bile and i hate over this
direction and i think a lot of it is
just misguided nonsense they just don't
understand almost in one sense you know
and i think
it's kind of you know it's kind of a bit
like veganism in one sense
you know he wants he wants more people
to hate him
but i mean
i have vegan friends and you know but
that is the worst excuse i'm not racist
i've got black friendly
he said the doors
but i mean it's true that i've got vegan
customers i do generally have vegan fans
but it's interesting that
with when it comes to their
specific reasons for being vegan a lot
of it they don't see a lot of it comes
from a very almost myopic view
of the food chain of a myopic view of
how they want to how that how they want
to interact with the food chain and i
think it's sort of similar with people
who view of their role in society how do
you mean to talk to us more about the
vegan thing well it's like you know
so it's like most people who live in the
countryside
most people who see how you know
how the natural world operates
you know
aren't vegan
it seems to be an extremely urban thing
seems to be a very young urban thing
like 93 or 91 of vegans are aged between
20 and 30 or between 20 or 35. because
they die after that
most of them don't have kids
right most of them live alone and most
of them live in urban areas right so
they have this very kind of like
filtered view right
and
it's a bit like what you know our mutual
friend rob henderson would say about
luxury police they have this belief that
they think
enables them to consider themselves a
better person because of because of
animal welfare and all that kind of
stuff
but what they don't realize is the
knock-on effect that it has later on
down you know further on down the
social chain towards maybe
those inners kind of more service
economy or those in a more rural economy
and that kind of stuff right
so for example they don't think about
the effect of maybe the
woman who has to harvest their quinoa in
bolivia who can no longer afford the
staple crop because the price has
chopped through the roof because
somebody in islington is prepared to pay
10 times the value for it or they don't
think about maybe the
uh the deforestation for soy to make
their
you know their soy milk or they don't
maybe think about the fact that there
are
whole villages in central america now
that don't have any clean portable water
because it's all being diverted off
avocado plantations because everybody
wants to have a collards and toast
and they don't make that connection
for them it's just like
plant-based equals good
meat equals bad and that's the world
that i'm going to want to live in right
and
it's very similar i think with
you know i think there are a lot of
these beliefs i think there are a lot of
these things that they don't they just
don't see how it can hurt other people
and that's not to say that they're bad
people for having their beliefs
you know i don't believe that vegans are
terrible people for you know christ for
the love of god i just think that they
have their view
but
i think if they actually went out and
actually had a look at the reality of
the food chain and the reality of what
it takes to actually bring food from a
field into your plate maybe they would
look at things a little bit differently
you see what i mean
and i think that's the same with a lot
of trans rights activists i think it's
the same with a lot of people who have a
lot of these you know these beliefs
you know and
you know they just they just
you know
we all live in a bubble really
but i think in an urban environment i
think that tends to be a lot more though
you know it's also about certainty isn't
it because if your narrative is
incredibly simple then you can be very
certain about it yeah this is a black
and white issue yeah this is completely
wrong i am outraged yeah something needs
to be done yeah
but if if if the issue is complicated
and requires thought and it's got nuance
and
actually you kind of see both sides of
the particular issue it's very difficult
to be outraged about it yeah and to
generate traction because you have to
put yourself in the other person's
position yeah you have to get out of
your comfort zone you know if you put
yourself in the position of the person
that you're arguing against in order to
see it from their side and most people
don't want to do that because it gives
the message because then a way takes
away your immediate righteousness
and it takes away the immediate the the
feeling that you must be it's the right
side of history claim
and then you takes away your crux of
saying well i can do whatever i want
because i know that fundamentally i'm
going to be vindicated in the end
because people will look back on this
and say that i was right
and you think
are you sure about that yeah the thing
that i find so
discomforting about the idea of the
right side of history is it comes down
to certainty yeah
how do you know that you are on inverted
commas the right side of history yeah
you must either be incredibly
intelligent
and
have powers where you can look into the
future
or
you're actually very arrogant yeah
yeah and you know these people who claim
to be on the right side of history what
you go and smash a local family-owned
businesses windows
and you are on the right side of history
by doing that um
well yeah
no yeah
yeah or you spend three days basically
on twitter saying that i did it myself
by saying that the glass broke the wrong
way
somebody with a forensic thing you know
what really worries me about all of this
as well because before you came in i was
saying to the boys here at the street i
was going do you think
we talk about trans so much now
and the thing that gets lost in the
conversation for me is
we've had a bunch of trans people on the
show
who identify or dress as or behave as or
whatever words you want to put to it as
the opposite sex to the one that they
were born
and we're perfectly happy to treat them
as they present but why wouldn't you to
respect them for what they are
and my problem with all of this is
how is this helping trans people how is
any of this helping trans people this
isn't about trans people this is about
some people wanting to have some kind of
righteousness and and i went and i did
and i you haven't helped trans people
what's happening now man is the research
is showing now acceptance of lgbt
people is going down
it's going down yeah because of [ __ ]
like this yeah you're not helping trans
people these people yeah i mean
there was my very good friend hadley
freeman said this really really
brilliantly she was like look i get the
whole fact that
each generation wants to have their
cause
you know our parents had their calls you
know for gay rights or before that was
civil liberties and gay rights and
everything and you get to a point and
you know and even douglas murray argues
this you get to a point where it's like
well for an organization like stonewall
for example you know set up by my friend
simon fanshawe who was at the event as
well you get to a point where you're
like okay great so we're now on equal
parting in terms of the law
so you know gay couples can then get
married they can adopt children just the
same way that that heterosexual couple
though
so it's like so what else are we going
to fight for now
you know and and and hadley would argue
and i think she's right in the sense
that you know it's also a great way of
telling off your parents if you're a kid
if you're a 16 year old kid what's the
thing you really want to do
you want to tell her if you're dad and
you want to call him bigger because
you've got that whole testosterone
surgeon through your system and you want
to you want to break out this oh dad you
don't know what it's like this is the
2022 blah blah blah
you know we've all done that we've all
been there so it's like so what's what's
the cause right what's the cause it's
like yeah okay fair enough fight for the
planet
okay you know uh fight for i guess
animal rights i guess if you want entice
him with a vegan thing and then you know
you know you can't really fight the gay
rights anymore you can't really fight
for civil rights anymore because legally
in the uk at least thank god
we're at the point now where we don't
have to worry about that anymore for the
most part
so then you're like well how else can we
do it
you know and i think
i think it is i think a lot of it is
that and i think that's why a lot of
people i think
they get to a certain point in their
life especially when they hit middle age
and they kind of start to understand
more the sort of nuance of history and
then they maybe they come out of it
maybe they don't i mean we'll have to
wait and see what happens now
but it is worrying that something
happens online and it's now filtering
into the real world because before we
would have said like look maybe three or
four years ago we would have said oh
these are just a few idiots on twitter
um
but then it's having real world impact
on your business with the google review
yeah absolutely hundred percent and
again going back to the luxury beliefs
things you don't realize that i employ
27 people so we've got 27 people if my
business goes down like any small
business like any labor dependent
business when your income stops going
through the door it starts winding the
first thing you're going to have to do
is make layoffs because like 45 to 50 of
all your income gets spent on staff
absolutely right so they don't think
about the poor guy who has to get laid
off because of the one star reviews they
don't think about that kind of stuff
they just don't make that connection
they just think
you know this guy's facially jk rowling
he deserves you know a one star review
and google for it
that's the end of the story and it's
like really come into the restaurant let
me introduce you to the guys who work
here let me show you what they're doing
let me show you the way that they're
turning their lives around
let me show you how they're looking
after their family and how they're
putting food on the table for their kids
you know and the thing about the
restaurant business as a general rule is
that
anyone who's read down and out in paris
in london or kitchen confidential
or has worked in restaurants
understands that
it's a bit of a pirate ship
you're working with guys who don't fit
the mold of quote-unquote polite society
it's like comedy it's like comedy
right
you're dealing with guys that aren't
quote unquote employable in an office in
a 95 monday to friday and there were
more people like that in society than
most folks realize they just don't see
them yes
they don't see them because they're
delivering their delivery on a friday
night they're cooking their dinner
they're washing their dishes on a
saturday night in the local restaurants
and they're doing all this stuff this
kind of whole hidden economy of
workforce
you know and the thing is that we've
always had a really amazing
agreement in this country since the days
of the empire which is
you come and do the jobs that we don't
want to do
basically
and we'll leave you in peace
and you know
we all of us come from immigrant
families in this room right and we all
benefited from that yeah hell i know
what my family did
you know my dad came here
as a 17 year old or 18 year old deaf
illiterate immigrant worked down the
mines
in cumbria in whitehaven
six mile down digging out iron ore
underneath the north sea
and then eventually set himself up in
business
there was like he could not have done
that if if britain hadn't been welcoming
towards that but the agreement was that
he had to do the jobs that they didn't
want to do
and it works and as long as that's open
then that's fair then everybody realizes
that
the thing is that when those businesses
that rely on service economy like
restaurants when they start to falter
you know and once those reviews will
make them falter
what happens to those people
where are they going to go because if
they don't have stable jobs and if
they're not working 55 60 hours a week
put food on the table and sending money
back home and raising the standard of
living everywhere that their money goes
what's going to happen do they go on
benefits
because that's pretty much you know
because if you know or do they just get
a job somewhere else or you know what i
mean it's like you've got to think about
this kind of stuff and we play guys who
are ex-prisoners
one of our best guys
spent seven years in brixton
he's come out he's you know he's got a
steady girlfriend he's got one kid he's
got another kid on the way and he's
really doing well but he needs work he
needs discipline he needs to be steady
work because otherwise he can't do it
i've got guys who come over from
you know from every country imaginable
to send money back home mostly at the
moment romania and they send money back
home and they raise the standard of
living in romania and the best way to do
that is just to allow immigration
because they can earn
five six seven eight ten times more what
they can in romania than they can do in
london just by doing the jobs that no
one else wants to do
pot wash salad wash food prep all that
kind of stuff right and it's easy to
snare at these people and it's easy to
say all that kind of stuff doesn't
matter until you get to a point that
we're at now
where
that labor force gets turned off
because of if you're a remainer you
blame brexit and if you're brexiteer you
blame
covert and furlough the reality is we're
never gonna know
we don't have a pipeline in place to
replace that labor force right
so that gets shot down that gets turned
off and then all of a sudden people
start getting their holidays cancelled
and they go well i can't i can't go on
holiday to to tuscany in half term
because easyjets cancel my flights and
it's only then that they realize it's
like dude who do you think's been
humping your baggage around the airports
for the last you know for the last seven
years
and it's only now that they're starting
to make that connection do you know what
i mean so anything i can do to raise
that awareness to say look guys any
opinion that you have about
all this stuff and anything that any
kind of um uh
was going to say any kind of um
footprint that you leave online
especially for businesses matters
because you know at the end of the day
it all boils down to employment and it
all boils down to people putting foods
on their tables for their kids but it's
like you said they didn't think about
that they clicked the one star yeah they
left a you know you know a crappy
comment they don't they don't care
they're on the right side of history and
they go about their day and they've
probably forgotten about it yeah and
then they probably and if they do it to
me they'll put and they probably spent
all day in front of that computer sat
there when they're underpants going one
star one star one store once and it's
like what can you do with these people
at the end of the day it's like how can
you convince them
to become stand-up members of society
and go out there and stop being somebody
who just breaks stuff yeah all day
that's the thing james because
destroying things is always easier than
killing them you know you've built a
business
that's what we're doing here and that's
why you know i've always admired you as
a person because of your attitude but
also people should know el portico is a
great restaurant the food is incredible
like my wife is always banging on when
are we going back when are we going back
when are we going back uh it's the place
we go to celebrate the birthdays the big
events the the good months that we have
here uh and you're a great host the
people are wonderful the food's amazing
so i know that our audience will really
resonate with what you've said here and
i know that you'll see a lot of them
coming through the door supporting the
business and it's not supporting the
business it's enjoying great food and a
great place so yeah
i'll encourage all of them to to go out
and check it out and we'll be coming
back very very soon james very very soon
um
you know what we've always got one more
question and i have a feeling you're
going to have a very interesting answer
to it the one that we always ask at the
end which is what's the one thing we're
not talking about but we really should
be
i would honestly say
[Music]
what's the biggest knock-on effect of
your opinion
anybody's opinion
what's that knock-on effect look like
you know what's the knock-on effect of
your your whole life philosophy that
everybody wants to pin their lives
around now
that's what i would say
james thank you so much for coming on
thank you for all the best
look i always believe that you know when
we started the show we were just two
idiot comedians who wanted to you know
find out why the world seemingly was
going mental around us but now i feel
that so much of this
this cancelled stuff and destroying
people's lives over things they've said
who they stood next to who they raised
money with or whatever
the only way that ends is if people who
are victims of that
are rewarded for making a stand yeah
and i know that that's going to happen
here with you yeah yeah and the
outpouring of love has been amazing
and i know that all of them there will
be people among that who will contribute
to that so
i'm determined that's why i was
desperate when you sent me that message
going serves me right for sticking my
head i was like no no
this is not how this is gonna go
appreciate it this is not how this is
this is not how this should ever go and
you're not the sort of person that's
seeking out attention or trying to put
yourself in a position to be canceled so
you can profit from it you're just a
good guy who happened to raise some
money and this has happened and i'm
determined that you benefit you do
better out of this and i'm sure that you
will thank you thanks for coming on man
i'm sure our audience will be supportive
of you thank you for having me and
thanks for your time and actually some
very interesting thoughts we'd love to
have you back some time to talk about
the restaurant business anytime yeah
thank you so much guys if you've enjoyed
this show
episodes always go out wednesdays and
sundays 7 p.m uk time raw shows are
always 7 p.m uk time same time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast take care and see you soon
[Music]
you